qu'est-ce que je suis content d'avoir ce
métier qui finalement présente très peu
de risques grâce à ce qu'on appelle le
montage clément retire les mauvaises
blagues les moments qu'il me met pas en
valeur du tout les moments même parfois
où je me des crottes le nez sans m'en
rendre compte du prêt par exemple dire
une blague extrêmement raciste comme
c'est l'histoire d'un arabe un noir et
un blanc qui rentrent dans un bas et
[Musique]
tout ce passe bien
bref c'est un métier assez safe youtuber
n'est aujourd'hui on va parler d'un
métier très dangereux
probablement du métier le plus dangereux
du monde mais personne n'en doute
personne ne réalise à quel point c'est
dangereux et il ne s'agit pas des gens
qui lavent les vitres des building hyper
impressionnant d'ailleurs nous allons
aujourd'hui par les messieurs dames des
reporters tv
c'est pour marquer la transition alors
y'a plein de best-of ce tube de fail à
la télé quand c'est du direct faut
savoir qu'une régie qui gère les
missions via le présentateur qui a une
oreillette on lui dit des trucs dans
l'oreillette on eût dit comment ça se
passe en régie et des fois en régie ya
littéralement le feu et c'est compliqué
pour eux de continuer à travailler et de
faire comme si tout allait bien et du
côté de ceux qui sont sur le terrain ce
fameux moment où il ya un délai entre le
gars sur le terrain et la régie les
genres sept ou dix secondes donc le mec
à 7 secondes entre le moment où il
reçoit le hockey mec t'es à l'antenne et
le moment il est vraiment à l'antenne
mais des fois pendant sept secondes il
se passe des choses folles j'ai fait une
petite sélection des moments de live à
la télévision les plus terribles les
plus fatales pour le reporter et je vous
avoue que ça me fait sacrément rire
allez commençons de suite avec mais qu
on dirait une scène d'un [ __ ] de
dessins animés je pensais pas que ça
existait des gars qui se recoiffe de
cette manière là regardez vous n'allez
pas en croire vos yeux c'est parti c'est
un mec film sa télé déjà on est sur un
niveau de non-qualité tahrir la régie
cas vu qu'ils l'ont mis à l'antenne et
qu'il était en train de cracher des
[ __ ] de malades en savons ce qu on
fait gaffe et demi est-ce que c'est trop
tard pour changer le plan ou est ce
qu'on le change quand même et l'on
changé on l'a revu ce présentateur télé
qui lui ne peut pas d'ailleurs caché
dans ses mains pour se recoiffer car il
a la cale vitaux ce nom mais réellement
vous saviez que ça existait les gens qui
crachent pour se coiffer ou c'était une
légende qui avait que genre dans les
bandes dessinées dans les dessins animés
mec jamais de ma vie je me suis dit que
ça existait pour de vrai j'ai une vraie
révélation en voyant ça attendait parce
qu'après il rouvre bientôt lui je vois
si tout se passe bien cette fois là s'il
ne recrache pas annoncées terribles avec
de la régie savent qu'ils ont fait une
énorme gaffe quand le gars c'était
recoiffer que tout allait bien ils ont
posé leur met à l'antenne par peur
qu'ils fassent une autre garde tout
aussi humiliante pour lui deuxième est
un truc trop drôle aussi avec les mecs
sur le terrain les reporters sur le
terrain c'est des fois il ya des gars
dans le fond qui comprennent pas qu'ils
sont dans le champ de la caméra et qui
font un truc un peu disgracieux et on
leur dit pendant et tu vois leurs
réactions live de réaction de mr dray vu
faire ça
c'est drôle parce qu'il a vraiment pas
fait exprès autant y en a qui font
exprès qui trollent lui il a vraiment
fait exprès à la feta bemba il avait
trop la dalle mais jamais les yeux sur
sa pizza il n'a pas vu l'énorme caméra
c'est hyper humiliant pour lui ok ça
c'est hilarant souvent ya des mecs qui
vont sur le terrain et c'est moins que
prévu ce qui se passe c'est moins
sensationnel et du coup ils obligés de
fake et une situation on voit par
exemple j'ai le genou il ya des
reporters qui ne sont vraiment devant là
où il ya de la casse et qui font olala
tout paris est en feu mon dieu alors que
que dalle mon gars c'est une voiture
genre dans tout paris et donc des fois
il ya ce truc là pour différentes
situations sauf que lui il a voulu faire
genre de situations et aigle inde alors
que pas du tout regardez il faire un
plat chaud un ouragan ça souffle un peu
on voit il a du mal à tenir debout on a
peur m qui s'envole et qui se passe mal
quoi le gall risque sa vie pour nous
apporter des infos et meeke et même le
schéma genre waouh ça secoue tellement
ne sortait pas regardons les voit bien
derrière ils sont au calme mais qu il
n'est pas parti si loin que ça
d'ailleurs seul talent ça a l'air
vraiment arrête à de vouloir prouver
alors ça tu t'habilles un cerf-volant et
tu prend particulièrement le vent soit
tu mens totalement en vrai il y avait
quand même un [ __ ] de gand qui passait
sur le territoire donc c'est chaud c'est
dangereux et tout mais au moment où tu
tournes cette séquence il ya du vent
mais tu risque pas de mourir et de
t'envoler quoi alors pourquoi revers des
caisses la réaction
j'adore voir la réaction des gens quand
ils comprennent qu'ils viennent de faire
un truc de merde cette expression de
visage
indescriptible je m'en nourris ça c'est
ça dont je parle ce moment là à regarder
ah les nourrissons nous parfait des fois
on dirait que la régie compris ce genre
la régie elle s'est dit on va faire le
switch maintenant c'est ok c'est trop
bizarre en fait la régie moi je suis
convaincu que la régie a sa part de
responsabilité dans tout ces petits
moments de gêne là elle est responsable
ça m'est arrivé une fois au parc à
chiens j'étais aveuglé par le soleil
j'ai dit monsieur ne prenait pas mon
chien comme ça parce qu'elle avait pris
par le cou pour le caresser
mais en réalité c'était une dame autant
vous dire que l'ambiance était
absolument horrible on retrouve pour les
sports les nike on va parler de
l'arbitrage vidéo sainz et son retour
sur les terrains widevine cette fois
mais une toute petite incursion l'année
d'un canapé mec change de sponsors m en
plus t'as pas l'air très très lourd
c'est un pied se pète candidats zoom sur
le canapé c'est qu'il faut changer de
marque de canapé
parce que si on speed structure est tout
autre cet accord
dans la vidéo
pourquoi toi qui est derrière la caméra
pourquoi tu lui as pattes non en vrai
l'a fait exprès à 100 depuis elle kiffe
dix fois plus avant alors ça ce moment
là c'est le moment le plus incroyable de
un truc qui a foiré en direct en gros il
ya un énorme problème en régie et le mec
en plateau il a dû garder son calme je
vous jure en aucun cas vous avez envie
que ça vous arrive donc l'émission
commence là c'est le générique de
l'émission de vie si news grosse
émission b messieurs on parle pas d'un
truc un daeu quoi grosse émission grands
moyens voilà ça commence dans quinze
secondes
ah là là j'ai hâte que mon émission
commence walhalla comme j'ai hâte de la
voir quoi est-il assez bon
ok ce moment là c'est bon
[Musique]
oria c'est bon là c'est bon ça non mais
ça on vient de
[Musique]
boudjellal youtube play on dirait un
[ __ ] youtube poop c'est incroyable
mais c'est un gag
j'aurais toutefois s'ils ont des boucles
et jabou qu'elle commence par ce truc là
breaking news est donc en échange de
boue quand il s'est trouvé la bonne
books armelle breaking news à chaque
fois en boucle c'est terrible rial et
derrière ils parlent entre eux là bas il
parle russe et sept résout le problème
ça se voit il regarde son collègue il ya
clairement un gros problème et lui il
attend il s'écrie un est prêt dans
l'oreillette sa gueule il attend il se
disait je perds mon emploi peut-être
derrière régie lui rigole il ose rire
s'il n'est pas au fond il est pas devant
la caméra il peut se permettre à ces
deux personnes comprend qui est le
fautif dans tout ça qui est le fautif
chaque courant rigide sa cour en régie
vous dire le niveau des tresses comment
ça finit vaste histoire et ouakka une
solution je veux que le grenelle soit
résolu s'il vous plaît ça va commencer
je te plait ça comment te plaît la fin
c'est que ça commence à quel enfer à
celui-là il est dur à regarder
il est réellement dire c'est une vraie
difficulté il n'est donc pas présent sur
la feuille de match mais [ __ ] mais
c'est capacité à reprendre normalement
ce qu'ils étaient en train de faire mec
c'est fou cette concentration ce
professionnalisme [ __ ] car en paille
ou tu vois qu'il sera aussi progrès
n'est donc pas présent sur la feuille de
match je suspecte ce gars d'être un
robot clermont un humanoïde robot c'est
obligé mais ça va tomber et c'est trop
penché
what watts et des robots mais classe est
pas possible là c'est pas possible
pourquoi la firme tombé violemment de sa
chaise sur un plateau très durs
probablement étude in youth trop bizarre
comme réflexe vu comme il est trouvé
personne n'en voudra de mettre un petit
temps de latence dans l'émission pour le
relever les décoincer fouet
bon c'est la forme ces vidéos ne s'est
pas laissé les appuis je voulais parler
de ce délire là dès la télé parce que on
chie souvent sur les reporters sont sur
le terrain blabla parce qu'ils en font
des caisses et des caisses pas tous mais
beaucoup parce qu'il doit faire du
sensationnel parce que c'est ce que les
gens veulent aujourd'hui c'est faut pas
les blâmer pour ça c'est paris soit us
par et surtout c'est quand même un
métier qui est grave risqué en termes d'
humiliations tu peux vite se retrouver
dans une situation compromettante ou qui
t'arrive un truc nul et que des milliers
voire des millions de gens le voient en
direct en voyant leur de l'amour et du
respect parce que je vous le dis c'est
ça le métier le plus dangereux du monde
c'est terrible et bien sachez une chose
je suis très contente de mon métier une
fois de plus je suis bien heureux de
décider quand je suis en live et quand
je ne suis pas en live ça m'évitera
convoi me décrotter néons gratter des
choses vont moins là et bien écoutez
c'est la fin de cette vidéo je vous dis
à bientôt dans une prochaine grosse bise
on sait une nouvelle phase
on dit je vous ai dit alors donc je vous
ai dit alors bon je vous ai dit alors
bon je vous ai dit alors dont je vous ai
dit alors bon je vous ai dit alors bon
don